I love Steve Jobs.
And you watch Steve Jobs put his black t-shirt on...
...and get in front of those people...
...and introduce the iPhone and the iPad and these iconic products.
When you see the leader out there selling the product...
...and selling the vision and selling the brand,...
...it doesn't only inspire clients, it helps you articulate the vision.
He believed that technology should seamlessly integrate into our lives...
...and that we shouldn't have to change the way we live our lives to fit technology.
Technology should fit how we live.
This is the reason why simplicity mattered.
This is the reason why design mattered.
This thing that he believed was so important that it drove all of his decisions.
It set their strategy.